je m'appelle michele mooch et rino on me
surnomme date en cas j'ai grandi dans la
cité la boxe c'était ma seule issue pour
ne pas tomber dans le business de la
mafia
mais on n'échappe pas à son destin et
j'ai payé le prix fort
maintenant il est temps pour moi de
prendre ma revanche rien ni personne ne
pourra m'arrêter
c'est le combat le plus important de ma
vie
montreuil où ce que tu fais
ce type là on puisse faire les choses
honnêtement si tu vas tu fréquentes je
te prends tu as bien compris la jette au
confrère contraire zhu pets sam envoie
directement au casse pipe
quant aux frères
cette fois je me bats pour ma liberté